if you found out that everyone in your
town was actually bloodthirsty vampires
what would you do almost everyone you
know is an undead monster out for blood
and no one is coming to save you i'm
going to break down the mistakes made
what you should do and how to beat the
vampires in sheeky this kid has no idea
that bloodthirsty vampires are coming to
kill him natsuno here has just
discovered a horrifying secret that all
the recent deaths in his village have
been caused by terrifying vampires
infecting men women and innocent
children causing them to die and come
back to life for blood most of this town
has already begun to turn and all of
them now know that natsuno and his
buddies have figured out this town's
horrifying secret and everybody prepares
for the fight of their lives natsuno
runs back home just as his family tells
him that a strange little girl has
stopped by to talk to him he goes to
meet her in his room but she's nowhere
to be found and this causes natsuno to
freak out this kid's parents have no
idea what's really going on but natsuno
knows that this little girl along with
every other vampire within this village
are going to attack this house tonight
okay this is insane we've just found out
that all of these deaths in our village
that we thought were because of a virus
are actually because of vampires and
this means that literally we need to
focus on preparing ourselves for the
horrors soon to come over the last few
months dozens of people died and if that
means that all of them turned into
vampires that means there are literally
dozens of vampires walking around right
outside and the fact that they just
showed up in our house means that our
only home fortress is now at risk
because think about it whichever vampire
was in our room could have snuck in
through the window and surprised
attacked us when we got home but since
our joy of appearance mentioned letting
in a strange little girl that means they
didn't sneak in they were let in by our
stupid parents which more than likely
means that this type of vampire needs
permission to enter our homes and while
our home is now compromised at least we
know this is a part of their weakness
but nevertheless our parents don't have
a clue about what's going on nor would
they likely believe us if we told them
about vampires taking over the village
because yeah that would go over oh so
well and unless we choose to leave our
parents here to eventually die which we
could do let's try and save them because
they seem like nice people i guess in
this case i take into account that
natsuno's dad is some kind of woodworker
or carpenter based on what we've seen in
his workshop with this in mind i would
wait for my parents to head to bed first
before sneaking into his workshop snag a
bunch of tools and make a whole crap ton
of crosses and since this isn't an art
competition they don't need to be
perfect which means i'll be able to make
a lot of them very quickly i would
litter them all around the outskirts of
the house hidden behind whatever bush or
object that prevents my parents from
seeing it and probably removing it which
would ideally create some sort of holy
perimeter fence around the area but
along with this i would also try and
plant smaller wooden crosses and stakes
around the house hidden under the
kitchen sink under the living room couch
and maybe even under their bed and in
their closet if i am sneaky enough and
then for good measure i would place as
many crosses wherever i can all over the
house in the off chance a vampire or
shiki does attack us while we're home at
the very least we have a fighting chance
now realistically this is a short-term
plan but as soon as daylight hits we're
okay we'll be fine and the first thing
i'm going to do is to get in touch with
the town doctor who has been at the
front lines investigating all of the
deaths because realistically he knows
way more than us right now and he's
probably the only one who can break it
to our parents as to what's really going
on we just have to survive tonight and
time is not on our side natsuno gets
ready for the horde of vampires that's
about to walk through his door and he
calls his friends to tell them what has
just happened he tells them that because
his parents invited a vampire inn this
house is no longer protected he tells
this kid to not let his parents invite
anyone inside their house no matter what
meanwhile natano's dad passes by his
room and sees all the crosses and
craziness and suddenly thinks that his
son is a bona fide weirdo natsuno later
comes back to find all of his vampire
protection taken down his dad tells him
to chill out on the religion and this
forces not to know to protect his house
the old fashioned way by staying up
sharp and alert all night long he waits
for death to come knocking on his door
just as he hears something banging
outside a black figure suddenly appears
but it has a familiar voice that natsuno
recognizes in shock it's his dead best
friend very much alive he cautiously
opens the door and sees toru who is now
a bloodthirsty vampire he finds out that
his best friend has been ordered by the
vampire boss to kill him but instead
toru tells natsuno to run from this town
before it's too late he then disappears
back into the forest at lightning quick
speed natsuno chases after him demanding
answers right as he bumps into this
horrifying vampire boss blue-haired guy
and he tells natsuno that his plan to
stop these vampires is about to come to
a horrifying end blue haired guy
prepares to kill him right here just as
toro slips behind him and gives him some
sheep to count the very next day the
town's doctor toshio struggles to plan
his next move just like natsuno he knows
this town is becoming more undead by the
day but he's all out of ideas just then
a whole mob appears outside led by this
crazy lady this woman claims that she
too knows about the vampire secret and
blames everything on this family who
moved in right before all these horrors
started she then drags a reluctant
toshio and the mob begins to bang on
this family's castle doors just then
this fancy lord guy comes out and the
mob demands that toshio checks this
guy's pulse to see if he is a vampire or
not okay now on the surface while this
seems like a bad idea to call the crazy
shaman lady crazy let's think about this
for a second we still barely know how to
kill these vampires or what works or
doesn't work on them this means that if
we barely know anything yet informing
the village about the horrifying truth
will only make things worse because
right now the vampires are killing off
villagers slowly and one by one and are
obviously the most active at night which
is when we as humans will be at our most
vulnerable so if we tip off these
vampires that we actually know what they
are and are going to do something about
it that's going to cause them to
accelerate their plans and we still
don't know for sure where they sleep or
how effectively to kill them so the best
method while it sucks would be actually
to do what toshio is doing right now
until we figure out a proper plan of how
to deal with these things play ball and
don't cause any trouble that we can
avoid for now and also for the sake of
common sense let's think about this for
a second these vampires are probably
centuries old which means they're more
than likely have dealt with dozens if
not hundreds of people over the years
who've gotten too close to finding out
their real secret being a vampire means
keeping this truth a secret at least
until they affect enough of the
village's population means they're not
gonna do anything for now they probably
know how to act normal and how to trick
the villagers into thinking that they're
just ordinary humans toshio is actually
going about this right because the only
way to reveal the truth to the
townspeople will be to catch the
vampires with their undead pants down
when they least expect it until then we
just need to play it cool toshio checks
fancy lord guy's pulse but is stunned to
find out that he has a pulse this shocks
the whole crowd who then goes home
empty-handed and out of ideas but toshio
knows that this guy is up to no good and
is working with the vampires somehow
elsewhere these two kids run into
natsuno with wild ideas on how to save
this town from horrifying vampires but
something is not right with him and he
shows them that he's been bitten it
won't be long before he turns into a
terrifying monster himself natsuno tells
these kids to run far away from him and
never come back but he has no idea that
these stupid bastards will try to take
on the vampire army themselves later
that night natsuno catches toru near his
family's house and he tries to convince
his best friend to work together with
him natsuno thinks the vampires and
humans can live together in this town
and he even offers to let toru feed on
him until he figures out a proper plan
to save this village but toru is too
hungry to listen and attacks natsuno
without a second thought and he feasts
on his best friend's blood forcing
natsuno to give up all hope he knows
that he now can't save anybody and he
soon will turn into the very thing that
took so many innocent lives the next day
these two kids show up back at natsuno's
door and prepare to discuss their
ongoing attack plans but that's when
natano's father answers the door and
gives them horrifying news he tells them
that not to know is dead okay this is
horrifying and now our only vampire
hunting ally is dead this means we can
no longer rely on anyone else to put a
stop to this except ourselves but let's
be honest here we're kids barely tall
enough to ride a roller coaster and the
boy is barely man enough to handle a
japanese shape kit so what are we really
talking about here our ally is dead and
convincing our parents at this point
won't do much because they won't believe
any vampire story we tell them until
they see one for themselves which they
won't believe it anyways and to top off
the bad news if the vampires get us that
means we'll become one of them which
means we'll turn immortal and live
forever which sounds great at first to
live forever but i don't know about you
guys the thought of being stuck in a 10
year old's body forever sounds even more
terrifying than becoming a vampire
itself think about it we won't ever be
able to go watch an r-rated movie drive
a car fit in adult-sized clothes heck we
won't even be able to go to a bar
without somebody telling us we can't be
there or worse try to talk to us in a
very very bad way this means it's even
more terrifying if we got turned into a
vampire at this moment so we really
gotta think about how to play our cards
moving forward it's not clear if natsuno
through his research taught the kids
everything he knows about vampires or
shiki but it's easy to assume that him
caring for them means that these kids
would have already been told something
about how to protect themselves such as
by wearing religious amulets or being
possession of any type of holy relic if
natsuno didn't tell these kids squat on
how to protect themselves i would then
first try to study up on these creatures
the same way natsuno did learn
everything i can about the various lore
and mythological tales throughout
history that mentions these creatures
but their house has likely already been
compromised just like natsuno's house
the vampires or shiki will find their
way in since they know where these kids
live so if i were these snotty-nosed
kids i would head back home knock my
mother out sorry mom make sure that she
goes to sleep for a long time tie her up
steal her wallet and cash and swipe the
family truck if they have one and go
straight to another location for an
attitude like a motel or something these
kids need to hide for a period of time
out in a place that is not their own
registered address and learn all that
they can on what these vampire bastards
are and figure out their next move and
whether or not they should leave town
and if so where to because realistically
being children this is their best bet
and only plan that they have right now
back at the clinic tosho finds out that
his wife who came to visit him has also
fallen dangerously sick but this doctor
suddenly realizes that his wife is the
key to stopping the vampires he'll need
to do something horrifyingly bad to his
wifey if he wants to save this town and
he prepares her to be his first vampire
test subject meanwhile these two kids
suddenly find out that the vampire virus
has just killed their dad their mom has
no idea what's really going on and calls
the town's newly opened up health clinic
for help but she has no idea of the
horrors that this health clinic is
capable of suddenly a knock is heard at
the front door and this creepy old guy
shows up and he prepares to take their
father down to their health center
called the ibuchi clinic meanwhile
across town tosho begins recording his
fiancee's vampire transformation and
begins committing the most horrifying
experiments on her to find out their
weaknesses he discovers that these
creatures are sensitive to sunlight have
regenerative powers and can't be harmed
from poisons and chemicals of any kind
but suddenly this girl wakes up shocked
to find toshio killing her slowly she
tries to break free and begs for her
precious life but toshio ignores her
completely and continues to fiddle with
his wife and not in the good way okay
this is insane they got our dealy
beloved and forced us to clean up their
mess although it's about dang time that
we have our very own test subject and
tosho should have honestly done this way
sooner basically the stuff that he's
tried out on his wife so far was
something that you'd find in a
kidnapper's daily work bag and he notes
that general anesthesia was not
effective in working on his wife nor was
another type of general at a static that
he used and he even used morphine
basically so far all the types of pain
reliever drugs have not worked on his
vampire wife which makes me think that
even though these creatures technically
do not have a pulse their body due to
the ineffectiveness of the sedation
drugs that toshio just gave makes me
think that their body is still in some
type of bio-functioning state which
allows their bodily processes to
metabolize whatever poison or sedative
that we give them this means that
they're alive to some degree and it also
means that the vampiric or cheeky
disease could conform to the laws and
physics of nature they're not cheeky are
vampires due to magic or some random
crap but rather an actual disease that
causes them to possess traits of a
vampire and in fact what we see as a
vampire may not even be a vampire at all
but a mere association with something
that we as a society began to link to
vampires what i'm saying is is that this
creature could be something else
entirely such as a wendigo which is
known to be a mythological creature that
is often associated and linked to that
of a werewolf vampire some combination
thereof it is possible that this
creature is some undead character that
resembles a vampire but is not one and
it's noted that these creatures don't
have pulses but toshio does say that as
he cut into his vampiric wife's arteries
that the blood flowing through her veins
suddenly stopped gushing blood meaning
that somewhere else along within her
artery her body's natural processes
stopped the blood flow almost
immediately if the body stopped the
blood gushing when we cut into it that
means that there was some blood blowing
through to begin with despite them not
having a pulse you see what i'm saying
this could also mean that what we're
dealing with could be a more primitive
version of what is known in folklore as
a hemomancer which is someone that can
manipulate their blood at will and as a
weapon now i'm not saying that our wife
is necessarily a hemomancer or a wendigo
i'm just saying that maybe toshio and
everyone else should not automatically
assume that just because these creatures
look like vampires means that they are
vampires they could be a combination of
different things that could be a
creature of some other origin entirely
and just like what not snow did with his
film watching earlier i would look not
to just folklore or tales on vampires i
would study up on various different
types of mythological beasts we're
stepping out of the realm of known
sciences and creatures and by him
conducting his practical experiments
this may give us a more rounded insight
into what this thing is and more
importantly how to beat it like
frankenstein's monster toshio continues
to work on his monster to discover any
more vampire weaknesses that he can find
realizing that even certain religious
statues sounds and diagrams can hurt
these blood-sucking creatures if they're
close enough like a zombie he discovers
that the only surefire way to kill a
vampire is by cutting off their head
this is how you kill these undead
monsters toshio realizes that he's
finally figured out how to stop these
things and he prepares his fiancee for
her final experiment with a stake to the
beating heart silencing her screams of
pain and fear once and for all mercy
killing of course but suddenly his
vampire killing assistant and best
friend seishin stumbles into the room
and sees the horrors in the flesh he
freaks out and thinks that trying to
save this town has turned toshio into a
madman later tosho continues his
detective work and discovers that while
this virus has killed dozens of people
so far none of them have really died at
least according to the town's records
this shocks toshio as he realizes that
everyone working at this town center are
all vampires toshio stands paralyzed in
fear as this office worker tells him
that all the villager deaths that have
happened so far have happened outside of
this town and that's how this village
has managed to keep its town death count
to a zero making sure that no outside
government or police force finds out
what's really going on in this town what
is he doing seeing all of these vampire
employees go about their work day means
that this town is not merely a buffet
for these monsters to feast from but it
actually has all the workings of a town
infiltration this means that these
vampires or shiki aren't making any
noise in how they've been killing people
and now have begun the process of
replacing the entire town with their
undead counterparts if they were just
killing people it would be a lot easier
on us because it would be a lot harder
to hide the mounting pile of dead bodies
it would be easier for us as humans to
leave the town and get outside help as
well as convince the outsiders of what
is really going on but since this town
is already halfway on the verge of being
replaced with basically vampires this
means that even if we could get outside
help we won't really be able to prove
what's going on because how could we
prove to anyone on the outside that
people have been dying and that vampires
have taken over when literally the
town's death records are at zero
literally every single person who is a
vampire is still working all the jobs
that this little podunk town would have
this whole situation is nuts it's insane
if i'm toshi i'd call this situation a
day and bounce leaf town immediately
without aggravating the things in this
office because it's clear now that we're
vastly outnumbered and here's why we
should leave one without any evidence we
don't have a case and if we're dead we
can't present this case the only last
minute resort i would do before bouncing
out and getting out of dodge would be to
create some sort of big enough of a draw
to have outside attention come in
because remember this town has been
described as being isolated and cut off
from the rest of the country for the
most part and so our best and only card
left to draw from would be in the form
of a wild card we set off a bunch of
forest fires and also create a bunch of
explosions of some kind big enough to
kill at least a few innocent people i'm
sorry but it's for the greater good and
in doing this i think this will be the
most effective method to draw that
outside attention in because the
vampires or shiki up until now have been
very methodical with how they've kept
the death count to zero but i ask you
this how will it look when all of a
sudden a large number of people suddenly
die within the town due to a sudden
explosion this will look suspicious as
hell and will no doubt attract attention
from outside forces and will influence
the outside factors that the shiki will
be unable to predict i'm not saying this
plan will necessarily defeat the shiki
but it will take away some of the
control that these things have been
exerting on this town so far however if
we want to seal the deal that outside
help does come all we have to do is this
leave town as soon as possible go to a
highly populated area and then make an
anonymous call telling the authorities
that there's going to be a series of
bombs going off in our village and we
were the ones that made them we'll let a
few hours go by and let the first of our
explosives go off we'll call again
informing them that the first explosive
has just gone off this will make sure
that the authorities are taking this
seriously and get their behinds over to
our village a little bit extreme yes but
totally worth it enraged toshio
threatens to expose them all but then
suddenly he hears someone talking to him
and turns around he sees a horrifying
vampire lord guys girl she introduces
herself as chizuru and tells toshio that
he better stop his vampire killing quest
or i'll she'll let all of the shiki in
here eat him for dinner right here right
now but she doesn't want to do that as
she likes to feed exclusively on virile
young men just like him so she lets him
go for now elsewhere another death in
the village takes place and the bodies
rack up at the ibuchi clinic but no one
here realizes that this strange clinic
is where they're dead come back to life
and this group of savage monsters begins
recruiting more and more members tosho
begins losing hope as all of his nurses
quit and leave the clinic for good
saying that they don't even recognize
him anymore but all of a sudden
something insane shows up right at
toshio's doorstep natsuno back from the
dead and he briefly stops by to let
toshio know that he's not alone in this
fight and tells them that the only way
to stop these horrifying monsters will
be to catch them with their pants down
the next morning these kids find out
that just like their father their mother
has just died which angers the duo and
this is the last straw but this kid
especially thinks he's more man than boy
and runs off to fight solo last minute
roaming the streets with rage and fury
he finds what looks like an abandoned
and closed off building but he thinks
this is the secret home for a vampire or
a cheeky nest he runs inside without any
backup like an idiot and finds a single
sleeping vampire one whisper away from
waking up with nothing to lose anymore
he prepares to kill this bastard here
and now but suddenly fudges it up and
gets knocked out later that day natsuno
shows up again to speak with toshio and
mentions of a plan to reveal to this
village the existence of vampires once
and for all using the up-and-coming town
festival as the perfect opportunity he
tells toshio that they must kill them
all including him and the two get to
work on their final plan but the next
day couldn't be more horrifying as
toshio wakes up exhausted as hell and
finds the grim reaper standing right in
front of him chizuru toshio tries to
kill her but his steak is suddenly shot
from the window by chijuru's helper lord
guy tosho then suddenly declares that
he's done trying to help ungrateful
people and now that he is finally ready
to walk over to the dark side chijuru is
delighted to hear this as she gets her
little man toy and bites on his sweet
flesh and she puts him under her spell
and orders him to destroy all of his
vampire research and obey her from now
on later that day blue haired guy
arranges a meeting with natsuno unlike
everybody else he knows that this kid is
unique and is not obeying any orders and
mentions tonatsuno that he already knows
that he's just like blue-haired guy
natsuno has turned into something more
than just a normal sheiki or a vampire
basically he's turned into a gene roe a
vampire basically like blade stronger
faster than any ordinary sheekie and can
survive the sun but these creatures
still need to feed on human flesh in
order to maintain their powers and he
can tell that natsuno hasn't fed on
anything blue haired guy tells natsuno
that if he doesn't join the vampire side
soon he'll die and he leaves natsuno to
think about his horrifying offer okay
this is insane what blue haired guy is
basically saying is that him and natsuno
are part of a subspecies of vampire that
basically function like blade from the
marvel comics all the benefits of a
vampire with no real weaknesses unlike
regular pupushiki these guys transform
right at the brink of death technically
never actually dying just transforming
this could explain how their physiology
differs than regular sheikh who only
transform after their human death and if
we look carefully blue haired guy as a
general has been calm his balls
throughout this entire situation up
until now gene rowe in general have a
brain that functions much more similar
to that of a human allowing them to have
all the ruthlessness and power that
comes with being a sheiky along with
being able to control their emotions
perfectly being able to survive out in
the sun and live on human food but the
fact that blue-haired guy just lost his
cool here makes me think that we can use
this if we're able to enrage him in some
way and make him react to a situation on
instinct and feeling rather than logic
have you ever seen an animal lose their
[ __ ] that's the plan here in this sense
i would begin by considering any and all
things that blue haired guy cares about
such as white hair chick chizuru herself
if we can find a way for someone to hold
her hostage and hurt her in front of
blue haired guy i think we could have a
real shot at angering him to the point
where his rage clouds his judgment
allowing us to kill both of them which
would devastate the cheeky side or even
more ideally by holding chizuru hostage
we'll be able to bend blue-haired guy to
our will also if i was a general like
not snow i'd spend less time moping
around and dressed like a goth boy and
would spend more time trying to
understand just how powerful i can be as
a cheeky vampire hybrid natsuno should
take some time now while he's free and
test out his powers by himself he could
get super creative and kidnap a regular
weaker cheeky vampire to test his powers
on he'll be able to channel his inner
psychopath and make this sheiki his
little plaything i'm just saying he's
gotta get a move on and figure out his
powers asap back at the clinic toshio
now under chijuru's mind control reports
to her that he's destroyed all of his
vampire research he suddenly notices the
lights from the town festival in the
distance and suggests that they should
pay the festival a visit and chizuru
agrees on the way she tells toshio all
about their evil plan to take over this
entire village and use it as a central
hub these creatures are tired of hiding
and their plan is almost complete kosho
then says that celebrations are then in
order and he promises to show her a
night that she'll remember forever they
then meet a bunch of the villagers when
all of a sudden chizuru sees the temple
statues nearby and she begins freaking
out wanting to go home she demands that
toshio obey her orders but toshio does
it to listen she realizes that the
impossible has happened and that tosho
is somehow no longer under her spell a
villager all of a sudden notices her
dead cold skin and toshio says that
she's fallen dangerously ill and that
she needs to go to rest in the office
nearby chizuru starts freaking out but
that's when she notices something insane
on toshio's neck she sees an older bite
mark on his neck that isn't hers but
natsu knows meaning that toshio has
always been natsu no slave not hers this
was their plan all along toshio finally
yells out the horrifying truth in front
of everybody that chizuru here is an
okiyagari a shiki or vampire forcing
these villagers to check her pulse and
one by one everyone realizes the
horrifying truth this guy suddenly steps
in and the gang brutally murders chizuru
right here and now choshio then reveals
to everyone here that the whole vampire
story who they are what's really going
on in this village and how to kill them
and he prepares all of these people for
the hunt of their lives and they try to
take back their town okay this is some
next level type stuff i'm talking like
evian water type of bullcrap we finally
have the villagers on our side which is
great and the entire town is almost
under the vampire's thumbs which is not
so great here's what we're going to do
we're not going to go to the police even
the police in another town nearby that
won't work as we have little evidence to
show them unlike these townsfolk who now
know thanks to chijuru being dead they
finally believe us but here's the thing
if we want to play it smart i'm going to
tell all these townsfolk to let it be
until morning if we're going to hunt
these things we're going to do it right
because most of them will be forced to
hide from the sun which will definitely
increase our odds of survival and help
us in finding them because they're not
going to be able to wander around all
that much we're going to hunt them down
while the sun is out not right now while
it's night that will give the shiki an
advantage if we do and would only result
in more human deaths i would tell the
villagers to all stay right here and
park it right next to those temple
statues the shiki seem unable to handle
being near those things which is great
for us so we're all going to stay right
near those things until morning we'll
pick out some of the civilians who are
more capable than others and rotate out
throughout the night allowing everybody
to get some form of rest while still
having some people on the lookout in
case some shiki come by to visit early
morning the next day the news of
chijuru's death reaches the mansion and
seishin here says that the villagers
will most likely come for their throats
next blue-haired guy says that they
should leave town but this annoying
little bloodsucker called sunico says
that they have nowhere to go so all they
can do now is survive but this little
girl is the cheeky boss and orders blue
haired guy to go cut off the snake's
head the now leader of the humans toshio
but it's already too late the sun has
begun to rise and these villagers have
already stormed the vampire mansion blue
haired guy quickly tells seishin to go
watch over suniko as he leaves to go
kill toshio the villagers start killing
every single blood sucking bastard they
see it's a bloodbath meanwhile toshio
tells the villagers to bury all of these
vampires so no outside police force ever
discovers them but something is not
right and toshio tells this beard dude
that there should be seven more shiki
hiding somewhere and thinks that they
must be hiding within the town's
underground tunnels they gather outside
and prepare to go down through those
tunnels when all of a sudden this rando
is shot dead by lord guy hearing the
shots natsuno rushes in to try and stop
him but suddenly gets shot by lord guy
and he escapes
okay this is some authentic microwave
pasta from italy type of [ __ ] this
lord guy should have been stopped since
way back since from the very fact that
he is human and tosho being the one who
actually examined him earlier means that
natsuno could have been informed of this
lord guy way earlier when he actually
could have stopped him before he just
killed this dude and even then natsuno
could have just snuck up on him without
announcing his presence like an idiot
and now we're presented with a huge
problem humans empathetic to vampires
who want to help them either because
they feel sorry for them or they want to
become just like them and that is a
problem that we cannot have not right
now so here's what we're going to do
beard guy will be in charge of one group
of townsfolk toshio in charge of another
and we will be in charge of another one
by breaking up the townsfolk into three
groups and placing strong leaders at the
head of each group this will help reduce
the risk that the people who are squishy
towards the sheiki the ones who will not
kill them or even worse help them will
be able to influence the rest of the
townsfolk into not doing what must be
done and we can even take this one step
further by having beard guy toshio and
us look for the person in each of their
own group who hates the sheiki the most
and make that person their second in
command which will then allow us to
split up the townsfolk even more and
reduce the possibility of the squishies
taking over even further and this will
help establish a clear chain of command
and allow us to kill the shiki more
effectively back at the castle
blue-haired guy realizes that he can't
take on this many people on his own and
slips back into the shadows he finds
satin in sunico and tells them that
almost all of their kind has been wiped
out meaning this group is running out of
time to escape but tosho and his army of
ordinary killers begin to realize that
their winning streak is about to come to
a horrifying end if they don't speed up
their mission this guy tells toshio that
people from the next town over have
started to wonder why all the roads into
this town have been blocked and that the
delivery men and drivers have been
unable to enter this town they're
running out of time people are asking
too many questions about what's really
going on in this town toshio then
realizes that they must kill every
single shiki here by the next morning or
else some of them will escape for good
but toshio doesn't realize that the
killing is about to get oh so much worse
this guy suddenly reports that some of
the villagers have begun killing other
humans humans who they thought were
under a sheikis spell and this makes the
rest of these villagers realize that
they can't trust anybody and must kill
anyone who gets in their way even their
very own friends and neighbors and now
this group of hungry killers head down
into the sewers to kill the last
remaining okiyagari that are hiding even
the scared ones and now both sides fight
for their lives the whole town has gone
nuts and it's a bloodbath countless
humans and vampires get brutally
murdered within minutes and these
villagers drag the last remaining
vampires out and chained them to these
trees watching them burn and they sing
beautiful songs to mask their horrifying
screams even lord guy gets found and
hypnotized by natsuno to burn himself
alive the screams have now reached the
burning vampire mansion and underneath
its structure blue haired guy finally
comes up with a plan to help sunuko and
seishin escape ordering them to sneak
into this car and drive out the back and
he'll distract the villagers but outside
tosho and the villagers accidentally
discover seishin on the run and chase
him down just then his car comes to a
horrifying halt seishin now badly
injured drags sunico in this briefcase
around the mountain houses and temples
and he hides and watches his innocent
parents get brutally murdered by their
very own neighbors this horrifies poor
satian desperate and losing blood fast
he hides sunico under this rock and
leads the villagers the other way but he
suddenly passes out and leaves poor
sunico out in the open just as these
hunters realize that their precious town
is going up in flames this old guy tells
the rest to go get help from toshio and
he decides to handle little suniko
himself meanwhile toshio gathers the
terrified townsfolk and tells them to
dump all of the bodies into the fire and
to leave this town for good because
nobody can find out what went down in
this village right near the fire a badly
injured blue-haired guy tries to escape
this town as one of the last sheiki or
vampires left alive but he runs into
natsuno whose plan has all come together
the two jinro battle it out for a
horrifying last stand but natsuno gets
beaten to a bloody pulp and falls into a
vampire gravesite on his deathbed
blue-haired guy prepares to kill him
until he sees natsuno's explosive
package and he blows up blue-haired guy
all the way down to hell with him okay
this is some overpriced benihana type of
bullcrap natsuno should not have offed
himself the way he did and his annoying
emo self-hating persona having someone
alive from the jinro species meant that
he could have done wonders for the
benefit of humanity in the form of
helping us advance in medical
innovations since we could have found
out so much in terms of how his vampire
body works and how it could benefit the
human race toshio is a medical man he
should have taken note that not to know
self-hating ways meant that he was gonna
off himself after this vampire crusade
was over especially after nazino
literally said to toshio hey make sure
you kill me after this is all done toshi
should have taken the hint and tied him
up beef wellington style just like
gordon ramsay down in his basement and
from there tosho could keep
experimenting on toshio all for the good
of humanity elsewhere the fire has
engulfed the entire town and sunico
finally collapses in this building
exhausted as hell but old guy isn't far
behind and he picks her up and he
readies his stake but suddenly he gets
killed by seishin who is now a sheiki
back from the dead ashamed of all of the
deaths suniko gets ready to die right
here and now but seishin convinces her
that she's a good person all the while
as toshio and the rest of the survivors
escape their destroyed town seishin
escapes with sunuko into the bosom of a
new dawn if you don't want to get caught
in the middle of the war between humans
and vampires don't forget to like
comment subscribe and check out the how
to be playlist down below